dan as the talk gets going uh it's a
pleasure to have lenka
zadabarova here today to speak um
just doing very brief introductions but
i couldn't help but notice that lenka
seems to definitely have her foot in two
camps at different times of her life so
she got her phd at both
prague and paris which uh
two different schools and everyone she's
uh
currently uh epfl in switzerland she
just moved there this year i understand
and she's professor of physics and
computer science
and before that she was at cnrs at the
institute of theoretical physics
uh so we're really looking forward to
hearing what she has to say about the uh
uh theoretical physics and
satisfiability and
where the oh the title where the
really hard problems really are i don't
have her title exactly in front of me
but so
right that's that's the title so thank
you a lot some
and let me go with the screen sharing
and that brings me to the slides that
you should be seeing now
so i'm really glad to you know
have this half an hour or a bit more to
discuss with you
kind of my passion about the
satisfaction problem
in the workshop that is called 50 years
of satisfaction the centrality of sat in
the theory of computation so
you know you you probably all know way
more about something i do but
nevertheless i
want to bring you maybe a slightly
different perspective from what we
learned about this problem in
statistical physics
and i'm really excited i cannot be with
you in the beautiful building of the
calvin lab in berkeley
but you know at least i took the t-shirt
i'm wearing a t-shirt of one of the past
programs just to have a bit of the
simon's institute atmosphere
so to start you know despite the fact
that my background and studies were in
physics
the question that probably really like
fascinates me
most in in my research is what are the
problems that we can actually solve with
the computer
so i think this is probably a common
point with with many of you
and you know i will not be lecturing you
about the theory of computation
complexity about which you know more
than i do
so that's kind of the standard take on
this
but we also all know that these days
even the empty heart problems are
actually being solved in practice every
day
and the kind of uh you know most say
conjugated example these days
is of course learning with neural
networks because there is no
law many works this is one of the first
ones showing that even very simple works
in neural networks
with just three nodes are actually np
companies to to train
yet you know we have this explosion of
success with artificial intelligence
these days
and it is fair to say that we are not
close to have a theory that would
actually explain
why these problems that in the worst
case are np
complete or np-hard are actually
computationally tractable and
doable so that's you know that brings me
to the to the case of average case
complexity
average over some natural distribution
of instances so
you know ideally we would like to
average over the actual instances that
come
come up in practice but you know that we
don't even know what that distribution
actually is
so so to approach it we will be talking
of some artificial
distributions over instances so let's
start with this historical note
where you know in 71 we have the concept
of empty completeness coming
to light by cook and then
some years after that there were
series of papers by goldberg analyzing a
random ensemble of the satisfactory
problem where you take n variables
and m clauses and then you
include a variable in every clause so
you go through
all the n times m pairs and you include
or not that variable in the clause
with the given fixed probability and
this defines an
ensemble and this series of works
analyze the davis putnam algorithm for
these
for this sat ensemble and show that it
is actually running on average in
polynomial time and solves the problem
so this kind of broads uh i
i was told the community to to
hypothesize that maybe
mp complete problems may be all on
average easy so that would have been
interesting but these two works
in 91 and 92 kind of cuts
that uh that statement wrong because
they introduced the kind of
random ksat ensemble and
the other paper the analogous random
coloring ensemble
that actually does not seem to be easy
on average so how is that one defined
so the only difference between the one
of
goldberg is that in random k sat one
actually fixes the number of variables
that are present
in every clause so one has again and
variables
and clauses and one fixes a number
k in this case three and that's the
number of variables per
clause and then for each then one picks
the variables at random for the clause
and for each of them at random one
decides whether they are negated or not
so this defines the random case that
ensemble that
that i will be talking about and looking
the
important uh quantity here will be the
ratio between the number of
clauses and the number of variables and
we will be looking at
instances that are large so have many
clauses and many variables
but in such a way that this ratio is
fixed to some constant
and so if you do uh if you generate
random case of distances this way
this you know brings us to the to the
to this picture so the x axis here would
be this
alpha this ratio and the y-axis
on the left is the probability that an
instance generated this way is
satisfiable
and you have the blue green and red line
for bigger and bigger instances
and you see that that probability drops
to from one to zero
or uh sharp in a sharper and sharper way
and at the same time for the same
instances what is plotted is the running
time of the davis-putnam algorithm
that seems to be pretty small
at small and large alpha but it's kind
of exploding around this threshold
so that's that's actually the running
time of that algorithm is
the other axis so that brought
that brought the authors back in 91 92
to the conjecture of sharp threshold
alpha s
that would exist in the random
satisfaction problem
and the kind of realization that the
hard instances
might lie close to the threshold
so what mineco could i ask a question
yes of course
you mentioned those are the running time
of the davis putnam algorithm do you
know if that's the original davis putnam
algorithm
where they resolve against all literals
in all possible ways one one at a time
or
is it maybe so yeah i actually so that's
a figure that
i took from a kind of popularization
paper
of tom hayes and i don't remember which
variant of the davis putnam
is run for this particular figure but
i mean for the follow-up it will not
matter and morally i would believe that
it should not matter but
but okay if it does then i apologize i
don't remember
no just curious okay yeah this is
certainly not the cdcl
algorithm right this is the dpll
so this is not conflict-driven class
learning
no no i believe this no yeah okay
yeah but that's right that's that's kind
of just to report
to these two papers from from 91
so so then we will be getting you know
to
do algorithms that actually run in
polynomial time and whether they solve
the problem or not
so to get there i kind of jumped 10
years forward
and and show you these two papers that's
that's kind of the ones where the
statistical physics came into the game
so the one on the right was the first
one
where you know this was a kind of a
general discussion that this hardness
can be related to the thresholds
and to the phase transitions in physics
and the one that is that kind of really
brought some
wind into into that subject is the one
on the left by mesa parisien zakina
because that one
actually not only had kind of a
discussion that you know these are phase
transitions and there might be
related to hardness but they actually
had a very
uh concrete computational very concrete
method to compute
where the satisfactory threshold
actually is and they
you know concluded that this at this
number there is a there is an implicit
formula this number can be evaluated up
to basically arbitrary precision
and next to it they came up with the
algorithm the survey propagation
algorithm
that actually solves solved instances of
random instances of millions of
variables up to this ratio
alpha that is re that was really really
close to this
satisfactory threshold so that back
in the early 2000s was just not matched
by any
other solver so the kind of broads the
maybe the computer science community to
to say well
there is maybe something since they have
an algorithm that we do not have
so again jumping a little bit forward
can we make these things more precise
and notably can we discuss you know
where does the hardness actually come
from
and again okay so so so that kind of
goes to to back to to my phd thesis and
this paper that we wrote back then
and this is the title page of my phd
thesis with this picture of kind of the
bubbles that i will go through in the
next few slides
and i also i forgot to say that actually
this
you had few weeks ago a talk by amin
kurta oglan on the
belief propagation and survey
propagation so
you know that's pretty much the same
spirit and like all the results that i
will be
showing you are heavily using those uh
those same techniques
and i will not be really going through
details of the techniques but rather
discussing what they kind of tell us and
what
would they lead us to conjecture about
these problems
so let me start with that diagram
so these uh six panels are actually
snapshots through different values of
this alpha parameter so six different
values of the alpha parameter and so
each of these
panels is kind of a
picture of how the space of all possible
satisfying assignment
of the formula looks like and you see
that there are these
bubbles and some of them are uh
some of them are blue and some of them
are pink the blue ones
there will be clusters with frozen
verbals and i'm here defining what that
means and the pink ones without frozen
variables
and you know these can be defined in
various ways
and not for all of them we actually know
rigorously that they are equivalent but
the kind of working definition that i
like to think
about is that one takes this belief
propagation algorithm which is
an iterative procedure running on the
on the graphical on the factor graph
corresponding to the satisfability
instance
and then one initialize then one
imaginarily of course
imagines that one can initialize this
belief propagation iterative algorithm
in all possible satisfying assignments
so one is imagining there is like
infinite unlimited computational power
one can do that
and then one runs this pdf propagation
algorithm till convergence
it converges somewhere and then one
actually defines the clusters as
equivalence classes of these belief
propagation fixed points
so if from two satisfying assignments i
converge to the same fixed point
then i say that they are in the same
cluster
and the frozen clusters are defined in
the following way
that i initialize in a satisfying
assignment and then i
convert still a fixed point so if from
the initials assignment to the fixed
point
finite fraction of the variables
actually didn't move
and stayed fixed to the original
satisfying assignment
then i say that the cluster is frozen
and if all of them moved
then i say that or almost all of them
move
then i say that this cluster is not
frozen
and what the kind of method
based on belief propagation and survey
propagation allows us to do
is actually analyze of how many of
what of clusters of a given size so size
of the cluster will simply be
the logarithm of the number of
satisfying assignment that would belong
to that cluster
so those methods allow us to analyze how
many of those clusters they are what are
their sizes
and whether or not they are frozen or
not
and as we are growing the number of
clauses
with respect to the number of variables
this parameter alpha
the properties of how these satisfying
assignments are organized are changing
and i will be describing you one two
three well four important changes
on the way so of course this change were
all satisfying the assignments
disappeared as the satisfactory
threshold that you know that has been
conjectured and computed in this physics
work
so that one is kind of clear what it
should mean but what are these three
this clustering condensation and
rigidity
so let me start with the yes good
question what is the size of these
formulas that you
used what is the size yeah how many
variables how many clauses
so the so these are not experiments this
is a
this is a closed form computation that
is done in the limit
when both the number of variables and
this limit here
where was it this limit here when n and
m go to infinity and the ratio is fixed
and then the x-axis here the x-axis
is that ratio of course here i don't
have the numbers because the numbers
don't depend on k
and here i'm not even specifying k but
that
axis is that ratio and the calculation
runs in the in the
in the limit in the high dimension limit
and so these all these thresholds are
sharp so they happen at the very
specific
value of the alpha so together
also the the point the these are
clusters of
truth assignments so you're grouping
truth assignments based on how the how
the belief propagation algorithm
converges in the end
yes yes okay correct okay
and the finite fraction of messages that
means the
finite fraction of the variables keep
their same value throughout the
leaf propagation algorithm is that what
that's what
frozen that's the frozen ones yeah
that's what i call the frozen ones and
if i
if you know fine fraction of them
actually
are frozen then i color the cluster in
blue and not in pink
and you can actually like you can you
can you can that's pretty easy to
to to think that if you actually have
frozen variables you must have
a decent fraction of them it's not
possible that you only have really small
fraction of them
because they must create a kind of a
backbone so
so if you have them you have you know
bigger than some
number of them that depends on the k and
on the alpha
ah okay good thank you
other questions somebody was yeah but
you have to know somehow that the
formula is satisfying to begin with or
these so yes so the so that's kind of
when the satisfactory threshold
conjecture or you know you know
facts that uh with high probability
these uh these formulas are satisfiable
so this picture is true with high
probability over the
over the formulas so if you pick a
formula that is really big
with high probability this is what you
will be getting
and for all the formulas with hyper
ability will be behaving the same
from you know these like these
thresholds will be the same etcetera
they you know the values of those
thresholds all concentrate
so of course there will be exponentially
rare instances
exponentially rare peaks where something
entirely different is happening
so those i'm not describing in this
calculation okay
thank you
so about the clustering threshold so
how to di so first of all with our
working definition of clusters how do i
define the clustering threshold
there's the smallest alpha at which
actually
the cluster that at the beginning there
is one cluster that contains almost
all solutions so maybe not all of them
but measure one of them
and when this large cluster actually
breaks that defines the clustering
solution
so a threshold sorry so beyond the
clustering threshold so below the
clustering threshold
error two random satisfying assignment
will actually converge to the same vp
fixed point
and above the satisfied bill above the
above the clustering threshold um
different satisfying assignments will
actually
lead to different uh bp fixed points not
all of them
but that depends in which of the uh
classes or other phases we will be and
you know i always kind of have a kind of
geometric or static
definition of what actually this
threshold is right this is like about bp
fixed point this this is not
actually it's kind of doesn't depend
like on
whether i'm able or not to solve the
problem but then
these thresholds have actually
algorithmic consequences
and all those algorithmic consequences
it's kind of the most interesting part
here but
all of these are conjectures so for
instance this
clustering threshold you know is it does
it make the instance
hard to solve no but it makes
the the instances hard to sample so if i
actually want to sample
the satisfying assignments uniformly
and here the asterix is actually in some
pretty weak way that i just want
quantities that concentrate to actually
to actually be the right ones as what
they would be
on truly random assignment then
such sampling gets exponent gets hard
at this clustering threshold so that's a
you know that's a
precise conjecture that that we believe
stands
and there is you know this this paper is
for instance one that provides some like
pretty solid evidence towards this
but of course i mean beyond you know
this is still conjecture because at best
one can
one can hope to show that for a given
class of algorithms
but we believe that this should be true
for all sampling algorithms polynomial
ones
that actually at this threshold that
gets hard and below
it is not hard and
um i have one question this would mean
that at this point
um also approximate model counting would
be infeasible now
because they uh also counting would so
so approximate again in yes but in a
weaker sense than one usually thinks
about approximate counting
because it you know in approximate in
much weaker sense that would one
actually usually
usually because even in this phase
before the clustering
uh the even the algorithms that are kind
of sampling this big cluster they will
be missing the small ones
so one will be you know one will be sam
so that's
that's why this when i this asterix
matters so
so let me maybe say more precisely what
this asterisk means
so so if so imagine you
had a randomly sampled solution
and that there is some quantity that is
actually the same
for every random for almost every
randomly sampled solution so such as for
instance
um you know in how many clause how many
clauses are satisfied say by two
variables
so what fraction of clauses are
satisfied by two variables so that's an
example of a quantity that
you know will concentrate and um
and so sampling being easy in this sense
is that i can
design an algorithm that will actually
provide me solutions that are
sufficiently random that these
quantities will actually concentrate to
the right value
okay thank you thank you for the
question
so let's go to the second one to the
condensation
so that is a that is again defined
geometrically
that is a value of alpha above which
so i define overlap between two
solutions sampled as random as simply
their humming distance
and if i'm below the condensation
threshold
then with high probability if i pick two
solutions
they will always have the same hamming
distance between them
and above the condensation threshold
this is not true
this this humming distance between two
randomly sampled solution will not
actually be always the same number
it will be in some fraction of instances
it will be
of draws it will be some numbering
it will have a non-trivial probability
distribution
and another uh
equivalent although the equivalence
might be hard to
hard to show to prove a definition of
this condensation
threshold is that the
so the bb propagation is able to
estimate
the the how many
satisfying assignments they are but
again in a weaker sense it's able to
estimate
the logarithm of their number divided by
the size of the instance
and that is again some or some number of
order ones some constant and that number
is correctly estimated by the belief
propagation
below the condensation threshold and is
not
correctly estimated by the belief
propagation above the condensation
threshold
so that's in a sense a threshold below
which the bdf propagation counts the
solution in some very weak sense
and above which it doesn't and
the algorithmic consequence of this
condensation
threshold is pretty much nothing in
particular
like for we have examples of other
constraints satisfaction problems such
as the coloring of
free coloring of random graphs where
simple algorithms provably work
beyond the condensation threshold so
there is nothing really particular that
this threshold means for
algorithmic hardness of either sampling
or finding the solutions
and this brings me to the third one to
the rigidity
that is defined as you know that there
are
no more unfrozen clusters so the
rigidity
threshold is the smallest alpha above
which there are no more unfrozen
clusters
and the algorithmic conjecture related
to these
frozen versus unfrozen clusters is is
pretty strong
so that's kind of based on
uh on you know evidence collected by all
the algorithms that are actually
able to solve these instances including
the survey propagation or local searches
all of them they on on large instances
they find solutions that belong to
unfrozen clusters so how do we check
that we
simply initialize in that
in that solution and we see that the
belief propagation converges to a fixed
point where
the variables are not frozen anymore so
this
leads us to conjecture that it might be
the fro
that you know it seems like the frozen
solutions
are hard to find like none of the
algorithms that are known
that solve k-set instances of say more
than 10 000 variables
actually find frozen solutions
so and that's so that's based on
numerical evidence but so far this
conjecture stands
so that seems to be kind of related to
the
to the hardness of finding solutions
this rigidity threshold
that's okay is it's just just to remind
again
frozen clusters are one where the
solutions
have frozen variables and the frozen
variables meaning that
it's like a backbone to a set of
solutions
when do i say the the
does is that a minimum length for the
backbone that you
require yes so that that
there that's some fraction that is
actually relatively big thing
50 or 30 percent of the variables this
is because these instances the alpha
here
is you know the average number of
connection
of clauses in which a variable is is
alpha times k
so that's typically something like 10 so
so it's
pretty the instance is pretty thin
pretty dense
so huge part of this instance is
actually an expander
and if you actually should you know how
can it locally look like so that you can
actually freeze variables so that you
know it cannot move otherwise it would
you know unsatisfy some of its clauses
etc
so to actually see to have such a chain
of kind of constraints
you you can see that these that this
backbone needs to be
needs to really take a large fraction of
the instance
so this can be made precise and this
number will depend on the alpha and on
the k
but it's actually not small think 30
percent or 50
depending on of course the alpha and the
k
thank you okay
so so here just
some some a little bit of physiology
because here on the picture of course
had one picture so i put the clustering
threshold first and then the
condensation and then the rigidity and
then the satisfiability
so actually in random three stat the
clustering and condensation thresholds
are
the same alpha they are equal and the
rigidity threshold in the satisfac in
the three
sat is really close to the satisfactory
threshold
it's actually here i remind the the the
conjecture for what is the satisfaction
threshold from the physics works
and i also remind you that the survey
propagation works up to really close to
it
and from numerical evidence the rigidity
threshold is actually in between these
numbers so we have a paper on that
back in 2008 or so
so it's really really narrow this this
this region
but then when k is actually bigger than
three so immediately the clustering and
condensation threshold are actually
strictly different
and as k is growing large the clustering
threshold
and the region the clustering threshold
is actually getting
really far from both the condensation
and satisfiability threshold and the
condensation and satisfactory threshold
are actually
close to each other very close to each
other at
large k and the rigidity threshold
for the case satisfactory we don't
actually know where
it actu exactly is that's harder to
compute but we do know that
in in in a related problem but before
telling you about that you know that
kind of brings us back so
which of these thresholds actually
indicate the hardness of finding the
solutions
so so far maybe the rigidity threshold
was closest
but actually not so if i so neither of
them actually
so if we go now to a variant of the k
satisfiability problem the not
all equal case that problem where you
know we don't
well it's all in the name not all equal
is the is the meaning of the clauses so
that one
some of these analysis are simpler
because of the symmetry that there is in
the not all equal k set
so there we actually know how to analyze
where the rigidity threshold is
and you know just these three numbers
like the
okay the clustering threshold with in
the
not all equal case set is at this
scaling
here then the satisfaction is
at 2 to the k minus 1 k
log 2 and then the rigidity threshold is
about
half it's half of the satisfiable phase
but the clustering threshold is actually
much lower than that
factor k times and
all the algorithms that we know how to
polynomial algorithms that we know how
to analyze including the survey
propagation
and all the algorithms derived from
survey propagation
they actually all fail at about
this scaling so this leads us to a
situation where
the best known algorithms that we know
how to analyze actually
fail somewhere at the scaling
that corresponds to the clustering
threshold
yet unfrozen variables exist
much farther actually up to half of the
satisfiable phase
so this conjecture that frozen variables
are hard to find as i said stands
but this case shows us that there is
still
a huge part of the satisfiable phase
where
unfrozen variables do exist provably
from
non-constructive arguments
but we don't have algorithms that would
be actually solving the problem
so that brings me to the conclusion that
even on the level of being very
conjectural
but wanting to be you know solid and
wanting to provide you
a number that somebody one day can prove
i
do not know which number i should tell
you
if you ask me you know which of these
thresholds or which thresholds indicates
the hardness where's the onset of
hardness of sort
of finding a solution in the random case
that problem
we just don't know up to this day
so this is just a summary of this first
part
so uh okay i should probably
i see that the time is running fast so
so just this
to summarize kind of the timeline here
so
in the 80s we found ensemble
we kind of had ensembles of cases that
were on averages
early 90s we came up with the
people came up with the case sat that
seemed hard at the threshold
then the early physics works conjectures
that it is hard
in a glassy kind of phase
before the threshold then this has been
made more precise and
realized that it's maybe making the
problem hard for
sampling but not for finding a solution
for finding a solution
the frozen uh verb the frozen solution
seems to be hard to find
but we don't actually you know that
algorithms seem to stop
actually before the unfrozen solutions
all vanish
so that all means that in the random
case that we don't
yet have a solid conjecture where the
kind of hardness threshold
on average is
but in some other problems we actually
do
and that's what i wanted to do in the
second part of the talk
but some tell me i can take
how many minutes can i stop oh you can
keep going uh we've had we've already
had a lot of questions so
i think let me see you can go 10
10 to 15 minutes more is okay okay
i will okay cool so so i want so i have
two instances of
different ensembles of constrained
satisfaction
problems where we actually have a better
idea of
or you know not the better we have as we
have a conjecture that up to this date
stands
of where precisely the the hardness
actually
starts and so let me tell you about
about those two so the first is the
locked constrained satisfaction problems
so this is an idea that we had
when we realized that is the freezing
that is actually making the that might
be making the instances hard
and we were and we were kind of thinking
can we design an
ensemble of constrained satisfaction
problems where actually the freezing and
clustering would be the same
threshold and the locked constraint
satisfaction problems
is exactly that ensemble so let me
so let me tell you the definition so i
first will define
occupational constraint satisfaction
problem
problems where each clause has k
variables and
i forget about the negations there are
no negations
and now the constraints have the
following
me role they allow
only a certain number so now the
occupied variables will be say the true
ones and the empty ones will be say the
false ones
and the constraints they allow only a
certain
number of occupied variables around them
and not 0 and not k so it's not that
everybody can be false
it's not that everybody can be true so
to give you an example
uh so okay and then let me say what
locked will be and then i give you the
example
locked occupation constraint
satisfaction problem
will be such that you know in this table
of integers that are allowed
there are no two consecutive integers
that will be allowed
that's one requirement and another
requirement is that all variables are in
at least two clauses
so there are no single variables that
are not connected to any clause
and there are no leaves there are no
variables that are connected to only one
clause everybody is at least
in two clauses and so just to
show you you know the all possible
occupation constraint satisfaction
problems that can be defined this way on
for k equal four so that would be the
locked ones one one of them would be the
one
in four sat that would you know the sum
zero is not allowed one is not allowed
two is not allowed say
k minus 1 is allowed so this is rather k
minus 1 in k
or 1 in k that's by symmetry the same
there will be also the fork source up
where it is only the odd sums
that are allowed and the even ones are
not there would be for instance the k in
half in case that or two
in four sat that where the two occupied
variables are allowed and
the rest is not allowed and then the
non-locked cases that would be the not
all equal sat
or one or two in four sat where
you know the two that are allowed are
next to each other
so just to give you an example of this
like one or three in five sat
instance could look like this and this
would be one solution
you know each clause has either three or
one variable that is occupied
you can check and that would be another
solution again each clause has either
three
or one variable that is occupied and
for these problems as i said the way we
define them was precisely to make the
clustering threshold to be equal to the
freezing threshold
as soon as clusters appear they must
have a backbone in these problems
why because the way i define the locked
if you actually change one variable in a
clause you are to
force to change at least one another and
since these graphs
because every um variable is
at least two clauses are expanders
we will have to change actually
extensive number of variables so
all clusters must be frozen here
and and and again we can compute the
corresponding
clustering or rigidity or freezing
threshold and they are all the same
and the satisfactory threshold is
strictly different
bigger in these problems and this time
when we actually try the kind of
champions of the algorithms
in in in random satisfaction such as the
survey propagation derived algorithms
which in this case become the same
strictly the same algorithms as the
belief propagation ones
we see for you know pretty large
instances that the performance of the
algorithms really drops sharply from one
to zero
added this clustering equal rigidity
threshold in these problems
so for these and this would be another
type of algorithms that do really well
in random cake sources but in these
locked problems they stop at the
clustering threshold and don't work
in this phase between the clustering and
the satisfactory threshold
so so this is an ensemble of
constraint satisfaction problems where
the onset of the hardness of finding
solutions is
actually has a sharp conjecture and
seems to stand
up today an interesting remark
is that this conjecture that these
locked
csps are hard applies obviously only to
the np hard among them
because i i show you that one of these
locked problems was the source set
the odds in 2k sat if you if you want
in my setting but that one is of course
polynomial because it's a linear problem
over the gf2 so
and that one is solved by gaussian
elimination but it's
an actually a really bizarre case here
because for all these general purpose
algorithms this would be very hard to
solve in the same sense that all the
other
ones are so the gaussian elimination
stands as a
kind of algorithm that is that is very
kind of
in a different in a different class
so that was about the locked csp
and then there are also the planted
constraint satisfaction problems that
you know the way i define planted
construct plant it
um i will be talking of coloring because
it's slightly easy to think about it
and about the case that because of the
non-symmetry in the case that
it's a bit more trickier so those random
instances again
it's a different ensemble of random
instances where you start with the
solution
and then you construct the instance so
that that solution
so that that configuration is actually a
solution
so you can start with the coloring of
notes and then you only put edges that
are between notes that have different
color
you just don't put the edges that have
the same color
so this way you define a planted
constraint satisfaction problem
and in those so so those you can
actually think of them as kind of
paradigmatic examples of
inferior statistical inference problem
instead of like finding any solution you
may actually want to ask can i find
something close to the solution that i
started with
and that kind of
diagram with bubbles also applies to
these problems
and kind of the question whether we can
or not
find something that is close to the
planted solution
is actually one that has a sharply
defined conjecture for where it becomes
hard
and in the coloring problem that
actually
um
yeah i don't know i mean some can i just
go for one what two more minutes or do
you
maybe we could leave the discussion now
i'm a bit hesitant i don't want to
stretch it too much
you're muted maybe i'm muted don't know
plea please please go ahead for a couple
more minutes it's fine
we started a little late and we've
already had this question so oh
yes oh yeah i'm just okay
so so here i am back at my bubbles and
they're kind of very
similar bubbles for the coloring pro you
know clusters for the coloring problem
as for the k sub problem they really
kind of
are behaving very similarly when you
analyze them from this point of view
and it's quite interesting that if that
if i do
if i think about the planted um
ensemble of uh
for the coloring problem then actually
for all that is below the condensation
threshold as i defined it
before the planted and the random
ensemble are indistinguishable
there they are actually information
theoretically and distinguishable
so that's kind of interesting that the
planted unsung that the planted solution
is just one of the other solutions and
there is no way to actually find it
and it is after the condensation
threshold that these two ensembles
actually start to be
different and so after the condensation
threshold that if i didn't have
kind of polynomial time restrictions i
would be able to find something close to
the
planted solution but algorithmically
i am able to do so only much farther
and in the coloring notably for large
number of colors
the clustering is kind of at scaling of
the average degree of the graph that is
a q block q the condensation threshold
is twice that
and the threshold above which the
british propagation is able to find
something close to the planted coloring
is q squared
and here there is a conjecture that
actually the bitter propag
that no polynomial algorithm can
actually
do a better job at finding the planted
coloring than the village propagation
and that again like i said like that
it's a very bold conjecture
but nevertheless it seems to be true it
seems to stand you know many people
tried other algorithms more powerful
other classes and it's just not
so far happening that other algorithms
would be able to
beat the belief propagation at this task
and again here that's a sharply defined
uh
transition so for a long list so
so for instance here is an example of
planted five coloring
where you need to go to average degree
16
for the belief propagation to work and
if the graph has average degrees smaller
than 16
then it's conjectured that no algorithm
polynomial one will be able to find
a correlation with the planted coloring
even though from uh sorry even though
from
information theory kind of
non-constructive arguments we know
that with exponential algorithm it would
have been possible starting from
something
13 point something so much before 16.
there is this gap where no polynomial
algorithms are so
far known which is again very sharply
defined here 16 is really 16.
so if the graph is large and the average
degree is smaller than 16 no way
if it is bigger than 16 village
propagation does a great job this is
kind of the correlation with the ground
truth
what i'm plotting here so this brings me
kind of to this
conjecture about the hard phase in
you know think planted ensembles of
constraint satisfaction problems
but this actually generalizes to a very
broad class
of uh of statistical inference problems
where there is a gap between what is
information theoretically possible and
what the belief propagation algorithm is
achieving
and there is a big class of problems for
which the belief propagation is
conjectured to be optimal
in the sense that in the large size
limit
no other polynomial algorithm so far is
known that can do better
and this is just to show you just one
slide on physics
that in these planted constraints
satisfaction problems that reason for
the algorithmic hardness
is kind of from the physics point of
view exactly the same
for which diamond actually is a diamond
because at normal pressure and normal
temperature diamond
should be thermodynamically graphite if
it would actually turn into
graphite it would release a lot of heat
because
it's energetically much happier as
graphite at
normal pressure and temperature but it
just
never does so it would do so in time
that is longer than the age of the
universe so we don't really worry
and and that's the same type of
metastability close to a first order
phase transition that is happening here
in the diamond
as is happening in these bayesian
inference problems such as the planted
coloring
so that's kind of where again a bit of
physics kicks in
and here's just a list of other
interference problems where
the exactly same origin of hard face
was analyzed and identified so you have
things like the
clustering of networks and sparse
principle component
analysis and error correcting codes and
generalized linear models simple to
learn neural network
phase retrieval and you know i mean
those of you working in various fields
truly recognize some of these some of
these problems
and just to just do you know i just
another simon's institute program this
next fall
will be on exactly kind of these topics
the computational and
gaps in these statistical inference
problems
so this is the last slide uh
not completely last night the hard chain
challenge hard phase challenge is you
know if if you can find a polynomial
algorithm that would reach at
that would work at 0.99 times these
conjecture thresholds that would be
amazing
but i believe that's not possible and
what can we do towards like proving
something like this
well we definitely can work with classes
of algorithms
and prove that for certain classes of
algorithms this is not possible
and there is a lot of ongoing work in
those directions and that's kind of what
that semester will be about
and that's the last slide just to
summarize i showed you that in random
ksat
if you ask me where it is hard to sample
i know that's a clustering threshold i
can compute that one for you
if you ask me where finding a solution
is hard i honestly don't know
even on the level of kind of bold
conjecture
for the random locked constraint
satisfaction problem so you can just
think of this as a different ensemble of
k sub because all these are kind of
mappable to ksat
we do know where the hardness of finding
a solution starts at is on the
conjecture level
and we also do know in the planted
constraint satisfaction problems
and okay that's all all i wanted to
tell you about or kind of summarize
very good thank you very much it was a
that was a great talk very happy to get
it and link
applaud on everyone's behalf since we
can't do it properly
and uh we still have some time for
questions uh there's already one in the
chat window
and we'll get to that in just a second
and i encourage everyone else to be
thinking of your questions and either be
ready to speak up or typing into the
chat window so
so super teek asks uh do you want me to
read that for you
um the notion of clustering and
frozenness seems to be hinged
on what happens in survey propagation
belief propagation
why is this a natural way of defining
clustering frozen-ness
in the solution space what other
insights would be obtained we use
different notions
of clustering for example yes that's a
that's a very good question
so that's that kind of goes to the to
the notion that
that um the belief propagation is
actually and survey propagation is
actually in some
sense in the in the limit of large
instances describing exactly what is
happening
in these uh in these random instances
so an alternative definition of clusters
would be
instead of you know something more maybe
less mysterious than belief propagation
imagine that you run a monte carlo
markov chain designed to
sample the space the the space of
satisfying assignments
and that you initialize that markov
chain again
in all possible solutions
and then you let the markov chain run
for time that is linear in the size of
the system
not exponential if you let it run
exponential then
you know with a bit of like additional
noise you can prove that it will
actually sample the space
uniformly but if you read it let it run
for linear time
then what is the part of the sub what is
the subspace of the space of solutions
it will actually sample close to
uniformly
and those would exactly be the clusters
again
now proving that what i just said it is
actually the same
as what you get from the belief
propagation fixed points is difficult
it's
open but that's the kind of conjecture
behind why
we use the belief propagation survey
propagation
because they are giving us they are
giving us an asymptotically exact
description
of how actually these basin of
attractions of something as natural as
you know pretty much any did they
balance monte carlo markov chain
look like so this is why and that's kind
of where the the exactness of these
thresholds also
come from it comes from the conjecture
that indeed
the the marginals that would be computed
over these clusters are correctly
captured by the belief propagation
in the asymptotic limit when the
instances are large
okay so just just to clarify that answer
if you if you find clusters using survey
propagation instead of belief
propagation the notion of frozen
variable
or frozen cluster would be the same uh
up
in the limit at least asymptotically oh
okay sorry so so
i defined the clusters via the belief
propagation now
okay i should maybe say what's survey
propagation so survey propagation in a
sense
is a if you defined now a new constraint
satisfaction problem
that is kind of living on the same
factor graph but
is not the variables are not anymore the
boolean variables
but the variables now are the belief
propagation messages
then the belief propagation written on
top of that beauty propagation would be
survey propagation
so it's a kind of belief propagation in
a lifted space
on the same gra on the same factor graph
so i'm not really defining the clusters
via the survey propagation that would
lead
to a different notion of clusters if i
if i had
say like more levels of replica symmetry
breaking so
i should not you know you should not be
thinking i define the clusters we have
the belief propagation point
the survey propagation is a different
than a different computational method to
kind of
analyze the properties of the clusters
if you want
okay thank you um
maybe we have time for one one more
question ej yeah
yeah i had one i had a couple of
questions uh thank you again for your
very nice talk
one question was um i'm still having
difficulty understanding why some of
these threshold results would lift to
say some other algorithm like stochastic
local search for example
right because stochastic local search
algorithms are known to
solve large uh random problems
quite easily so are you going to witness
the same threshold behavior over there
or not that's that's one that's the
conjecture so even
either the local search algorithms will
be
weaker in this case their threshold can
be you know
smaller or they will i mean the bet the
conjectures that the best they will
achieve
is the same threshold so this is this is
of course uh you know that's beside you
know what you're kind of confused about
that's what like everybody is kind of
confused nobody really knows right how
to think about
why would these thresholds actually have
a meaning for other classes of
algorithms
so for instance there is a there is a
big line of work now about uh
semi-definite programming algorithms
sos sdp type algorithms sos
proofs and and these algorithms are
quite doing something quite
bizarre with the instances they're in a
sense projecting them into a different
space and yet
they are finding the same exactly the
same values for these thresholds
so there is probably something
deeper uh deeper happening here
that we are just not understanding yet
is just maybe
that these you know methods from
statistical physics based on belief
propagation were kind of the first ones
that were analyzed that
discovered these thresholds but my my
con
my kind of guess would be that these
thresholds actually have some
deeper meaning beyond kind of defining
them will i be
believe propagation kind of deeper
algorithmic
meaning than that but that's you know a
wild
kind of conjecture
okay um just to follow up on that
um has there been any work that you know
of where people have used stochastic
local search
uh kind of cross-verified this
conjecture against
stochastic locals yes so you see for
instance i went too fast right
but this when i was trying to persuade
you that these local
that this locked constraint satisfaction
problems actually
uh you know the algorithms stop at the
at the threshold so
you know close to three in this case so
here i was showing you the bp
reinforcement algorithm so that's
kind of a you know bp used in a way that
you can actually extract
a satisfying assignment from it and
there was another graph that looked
exactly almost the same
where i was actually using stochastic
local search
uh you know one designed kind of to
to copy uh some of the stochastic local
searches that
that are the best performing ones in
random casa
so those work almost as well as the
survey propagation
or say the same well it's it's kind of
you know it's kind of hard to say at the
level of that numerics
one could say that the same and and here
we are seeing
the same thing both of them stop working
at that threshold so that's for instance
one you know that's that's from our
paper in 2008 like one kind of numerical
evidence that that's the case
uh can i ask one more question sam last
lesson
uh so any work on structured instances
threshold behavior for structured
instances the structured
in which way uh for example the
instances that are
that come from verification application
or
software engineering and so on yeah so
that's
so not much that i know of or not
anything that i know of maybe there are
some that i don't know of
that's a very interesting question like
in the context you know
my group is now kind of looking a lot at
these like neural networks and
and there the difference between like
what happens for random
iid data and what happens for the actual
structured data is
is very kind of important and hot
currently
and so kind of asking that same question
in the that is it's very interesting but
there is not much
i know of thank you very much thank you
again
all right thank you for the talk again
that was great
uh we'll take about a three minute break
just to give people a chance to stretch
their legs so we'll start promptly
at 35 minutes past the hour for me
that's 9 35 a.m
uh thank you thank you again lenka um
thank you all
and if you have follow up questions just
feel free to to write me an email i will
be
very happy to to to discuss whatever you
were thinking about during the talk
thank you
okay good and uh
[ __ ] oh let's see if i can